il est 8h30 3 merci d'être avec nous sur
Sud Radio pour retrouver comme tous les
matins de 8h30 à 9h notre invité
politique et ce matin avec nous
Jean-Noël Barrault qui est ministre
délégué du numérique bonjour vous êtes
aussi vice-président du modèle et je
parlerai un peu de politique en fin
d'interview rentrée scolaire et
numérique lutte contre le
cyber-harcèlement interdiction de
l'accès au porno pour les mineurs la
sécurité numérique l'interdiction
éventuelle de Tik Tok ce sont des sujets
que nous allons développer mais je vais
commencer avec cette info en 2040 le
SCAF avion de chasse européen succédera
au Rafale il pourra transporter l'arme
nucléaire et sera connecté à des drones
accompagnateurs est-il vrai que
l'infrastructure Cloud et l'intelligence
artificielle
indispensable pour les pilotes et le
fonctionnement de l'avion ont été
confiés en partie à
IBM entreprise américaine
ce que je peux confirmer je connais pas
les détails de de ce projet qui est
porté par le ministre des Armées c'est
que les armées sont particulièrement
vigilantes à ce que nous soyons
souverain en matière d'armement et en
matière de numérique donc je pourrais
revenir après mettre un peu plus
renseigné sur le sujet précis si vous
êtes un sujet important
je connais le sujet essentiel c'est
l'indépendance de la France je connais
l'attention qui est accordée aux armées
qui sont très en pointe sur les sujets
de souveraineté numérique à ce que
aucune dépendance aucune interférence
étrangère ne puisse venir perturber la
politique militaire de l'indépendance de
la France soumission aux Américains
risquent pour l'indépendance stratégique
et puis et puis n'étaient-ils pas répété
ici ou là que le programme
Scaff devait permettre de développer
l'autonomie stratégique européenne et
c'est tout le projet du président de la
République et c'est vrai dans les armées
n'a pas été choisie c'est vrai pour les
armées et c'est vrai dans bien d'autres
domaines du numérique vous avez raison
de citer Thales qui a cet été démontré
une nouvelle fois qu'il était un leader
dans matière de numérique mais aussi en
matière de cybersécurité qui joue un
rôle très important auprès des armées ce
qui ne veut pas dire évidemment que il
n'y ait pas
au cas par cas quelques alliances qui
puissent faire avec d'autres déplorer ce
choix je vous le dis je fais toute
confiance aux armées pour protéger dans
le domaine numérique
et bien c'est qu'il était conforme avec
les objectifs d'autonomie sur décision
allemande le le ministère des armées est
constamment attentif à ce que nous ne
puissions pas dans tous les domaines de
notre défense nationale être soumis à
des interférences ou à des dépendances
étrangères donc je fais toute confiance
au ministère des armées dans les choix
qui ont été faits Emmanuel Macron hier
soir sur Youtube et Tic-Toc genre Noël
barreau a beaucoup parlé évidemment de
numérique et notamment notamment
le numérique
est le cyber-harcèlement alors le
cyber-harcèlement c'est rentré scolaire
où en est-on d'ailleurs est-ce que
est-ce que c'est en augmentation le
cyber-harcèlement dans nos écoles le
cyberharcèlement c'est la la poursuite
sur les réseaux sociaux du harcèlement
qui est un fléau qui trou qui touche de
de très nombreux élèves dans nos écoles
et contre lequel le gouvernement entend
agir puisque la première ministre
annoncera dans quelques semaines un plan
mais je veux d'abord rappeler
quelques-uns des éléments sur lesquels
nous avons travaillé ces dernières
années avec la majorité avec le
gouvernement d'abord une loi celle qui a
été portée par le député
Erwan Balan qui a créé un délit de
harcèlement et donc de cyber-harcèlement
qui est passible d'une peine de prison
qui peut aller jusqu'à 10 ans de prison
une amende qui est particulièrement
lourde et la capacité de saisir les or
les téléphones portables de ceux qui se
livrent au harcèlement et aussi
barcellement ça c'est pour le volet
répressif mais il y a évidemment une
dimension de sensibilisation qui est
très importante l'année dernière nous
avons commencé à expérimenter dans
plusieurs centaines de collèges avec le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale un
module de sensibilisation pour les 6e
c'est un module qui se fait en salle
informatique et qui la formation ouais
et qu'il est sensibilise sur ce que
c'est que le cyber-harcèlement et sur ce
qu'il faut faire et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire quand on est témoin ou victime de
cyber-harcèlement il faut en parler un
adulte il faut le signaler sur la
plateforme sur laquelle on est quand on
voit un message qui est problématique
qui a un bouton à côté qui permet de le
signaler et enfin il faut se tourner
vers le numéro d'appel qui est le numéro
d'appel 30 18 vers lequel on peut se
tourner dans ce cas de situation ce
module il va être généralisé à la
rentrée c'est à dire que tous les élèves
de 6e pourront bénéficier il est
généralisé les généralisé absolument
depuis
débat le 19 septembre sur le projet de
loi numérique du gouvernement que
apporter sur le cyber-harcèlement hier
le président de la République a dit
qu'il fallait bannir des réseaux sociaux
les cyber-harceleurs comment les bannir
éloigner en ligne décibères harceleurs
comment
le projet de loi que je porte qui a été
adopté à l'unanimité au Sénat qui sera
examinée dans quelques jours à
l'assommation nationale prévoit en effet
une peine complémentaire de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux pour les personnes
condamnées par le juge pour des faits de
cybards comment ça marche et bien ça
sera de la responsabilité des
plateformes de prendre tous les moyens
nécessaires pour veiller à ce que la
personne condamnée ne puisse pas se
réinscrire sur le réseau social en
question en utilisant des données de
connexion notamment puisqu'on n'est
jamais anonyme sur Internet il n'y a pas
d'anonymat sur internet on peut
retrouver les auteurs et bien en
utilisant ces données de connexion la
réinscription sera rendu impossible oui
mais avant la sanction judiciaire ça
prend du temps la sanction judiciaire le
harceleur pourra poursuivre sa victime
vous avez raison ça prend du temps mais
des moyens supplémentaires ont été
donnés au ministère de l'intérieur avec
la loi de programmation émissaire
d'intérieur à la justice avec la loi de
programmation de la justice qui vont
nous permettre là aussi d'aller plus
vite dans le recueil hier le président
de la République a parlé d'interdiction
de réseau pendant six mois
oui c'est bien la peine qui est prévue
qui peut aller jusqu'à 1 an
on ne peut rien faire mais vous savez
comment peut-on exclure des réseaux
sociaux harceleur avant que la justice
n'ait décidé alors c'est déjà possible
dans certains cas puisque les les
règles européennes que la France a porté
l'année dernière et qui sont entrés en
vigueur pendant l'été vont permettre aux
plateformes de le faire mais ce qui est
très important c'est que nous avons
renforcé les moyens de ministère de
l'Intérieur pour le recueil des plaintes
et puis le ministère de la Justice pour
l'instruction des enquêtes et que des
condamnations il lui et je crois que
c'est important de le rappeler à nos
auditeurs dans le cas du alors c'était
pas du cyber-harcèlement scolaire mais
c'était du cyber seulement de
personnalité dans le cas de Mila dans le
cas du chanteur Eddy De Pretto dans le
cas plus récent de la chanteuse Hoshi
oui les personnes qui se sont livrées à
du cyber harcèlement parfois n'était pas
au courant du fait que ce qu'il faisait
était passible de sanctions lourdes et
bien il y a eu on les a retrouvés et
condamné et condamné à des peines de
prison et je crois que c'est très
important de savoir que même derrière un
pseudo et bien on peut être retrouvé et
on peut être lourdement sanctionné et
désormais en plus banni les plateformes
collaborent el collaborent
désormais elles vont devoir le faire
plus activement car les règles
européennes qui sont entrées en vigueur
le 25 août dernier leur impose une
responsabilité nouvelle beaucoup plus
importante qu'auparavant auparavant les
réseaux sociaux étaient considérés comme
quasiment irresponsable vis-à-vis des
messages des contenus qui transitaient
sur la plateforme nous avons mis fin à
cette situation et nous allons leur
imposer et bien une forme de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de ce qui
transit Jean-Noël barreau je vais vous
parler des mineurs et du porno mais
auparavant hier le président de la
République est revenu sur le port de
l'uniforme enfin pas l'uniforme une
tenue unique vous êtes favorable au port
d'une tenue unique à l'école
plus favorable à condition qu'elle
puisse être expérimentée en lien avec
les directeurs
on est sur la même ligne que le
Président de la République que je pense
que la généralisation du service
national universel qui arrive un peu
plus tard dans le parcours mais qui là
aussi passe par une tenue commune un
parcours commun pendant quelques
semaines j'y suis favorable car c'est
une manière de recréer les conditions
d'une forme de communauté nationale par
le brassage et je pense que par ailleurs
pour traiter des sujets qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure et en particulier du
harcèlement et bien une tenue unique
nous verrons en tout cas ce que les
expérimentations montreront bien c'est
une manière aussi d'éviter d'exacerber
des différences dans un lieu où on doit
et bien créer les convergences entre les
élèves quel que soit leur parcours
journal barreau sur Tik Tok il y a eu
une poussée de fièvre de beaucoup
beaucoup d'intervenants qui ont défendu
la Baya et notamment des youtubers ou
des youtubers Tik Tok outils
d'espionnage du gouvernement chinois ou
pas
Tik Tok est une je dis ça parce que
dessinateurs ont été très sévères
l'interdiction de Tik Tok bien sûr Tik
Tok
et ses liens avec la Chine c'est pas
tout à fait le même sujet
Tik Tok comme les autres plateforme
depuis le 25 août une plateforme
d'influence c'est ce que je veux dire
comprenez comme je l'ai dit au sénateur
qui ont fait un excellent rapport Tik
Tok aujourd'hui n'est pas conforme au
droit européen 1 sur la protection des
données personnelles parce
qu'effectivement il est avéré que ces
dernières années des données ont
transité vers la Chine or la Chine ne
respecte pas les conditions qu'on se
fixe nous ça s'appelle le rgpd c'est la
protection des données personnelles
deuxième élément Tik Tok
n'est pas encore tout à fait conforme à
ces nouvelles règles européennes que
j'ai cité tout à l'heure et qui impose
une responsabilité vis-à-vis de vous
envisagez de suspendre Tik Tok la règle
est très claire Tik Tok doit se mettre
en conformité avec les règles de
protection des données personnelles
sont en train de construire des centres
de données en Europe pour pouvoir
héberger nos données sans quelle
transitent par la Chine et deuxièmement
s'agissant de leurs algorithmes de leurs
services depuis le 25 août ils sont sous
le contrôle de la commission obligé de
prendre des mesures de protection de
leur de leurs utilisateurs et notamment
les plus jeunes s'il ne les prennent pas
ils s'exposent à des amendes à leurs
risques de suspension il y a un risque
d'amende dans un premier temps qui peut
aller jusqu'à 6% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial de dire 600 millions d'euros et
s'il y avait des manquements répétés si
Tik Tok ne se mettait pas au pas alors
la Commission européenne pourrait
décider d'une d'un bannissement de Tik
Tok de l'Union européenne est-ce qu'il y
a un contrôle effectif de l'âge des
utilisateurs aujourd'hui non mais nous
avons adopté au printemps une loi portée
par un député de la majorité Laurent
marquantelli qui vieux obligé les
plateformes à faire un une vérification
d'âge sérieuse des utilisateurs et je
pense que c'est très important hier
matin je suis allé dans des
établissements collège et lycées pour
souhaiter une bonne rentrée aux élèves
et leur donner aussi quelques clés pour
limiter les risques et en ligne est-ce
que j'ai constaté c'est que même dans
des petites classes même dans des
classes de 6e des élèves qui n'avaient
pas encore 13 ans étaient déjà inscrit
sur Tik Tok alors que Tik Tok fixe une
limite de 13 ans pour s'inscrire et cela
c'est tout simplement parce que l'âge
n'est pas vérifié sérieusement cette
situation nous voulons y mettre fin nous
voulons d'abord y mettre bon pour la
question du porno car aujourd'hui venir
je vais y venir c'est c'est révoltant et
bien avec des solutions que des
entreprises françaises européennes
peuvent développer nous sommes en lien
avec elle nous constatons que le défi
technique n'est pas insurmontable qui
permettra et bien à la fois s'agissant
du porno en tout cas d'avoir une
garantie de l'âge de utilisateurs mais
aussi une une garantie d'absence de
fichage et de protection des données
personnelles à propos de je vais je vais
venir sur le porno et les mineurs à
propos de l'usage du téléphone à l'école
est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut fixer des
règles plus strictes je ne sais pas moi
dans les établissements scolaires dans
les établissements des règles ont été
prises
vous savez je crois que il me semble que
l'un des sujets majeurs c'est et c'est
bien le problème du cyber-harcellement
c'est c'est qu'il se déplace sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur les boucles
WhatsApp mais à l'extérieur du temps
scolaire donc je crois que la réponse
c'est la vérification d'âge c'est la
restauration de de l'autorité parentale
de ce qu'on appelle désormais de
téléphone évidemment pas de téléphone en
classe évidemment et ensuite bien avoir
conscience et là je m'adresse aux
parents que les smartphones les
téléphones portables qu'ils achètent
pour leurs enfants sont des outils qui
ont été conçus par des adultes pour des
adultes et qu'il n'est pas concevable de
laisser entre les mains ce type d'outils
sans accompagner les enfants et c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles on a
pris une loi qui va entrer en vigueur en
début d'année prochaine qui généralise
qu'on appelle le contrôle parental sur
l'ensemble des appareils qui sont vendu
sur notre sol justement le contrôle
parental les mineurs et le porno une
simple déclaration de majorité est
insuffisante non seulement c'est
insuffisant mais c'est un scandale parce
que vous avez aujourd'hui en France 2
millions d'enfants qui sont exposés
chaque mois au contenu pornographiques
pas que sur Internet on est bien
d'accord sur Twitter sur telegram sur
snapchat enfin du porno on peut en
trouver partout absolument et un mineur
peut trouver du porno partout
aujourd'hui un mineur est parmi les plus
jeunes il faut se dire qu'aujourd'hui
dans notre pays les les petits garçons
de 12 ans et bien il y en a la moitié
qui sont exposés chaque mois à de la
peur comment faire et bien nous compris
des mesures
il y a deux ans pour imposer une
vérification d'âge ou aussi de
pornographique en disant sinon le juge
pourra ordonner votre blocage la
situation n'a pas évolué rien c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous allons durcir
dans le projet de loi que je porte c'est
l'arcom qui sans passer par le juge lard
comme c'est le gendarme d'Internet et
des médias l'arc comme pourra sans
passer par le juge ordonner le blocage
en quelques semaines des sites
pornographiques qui vérifieront pas
l'âge de leurs utilisateurs
et donc on ne pouvait pas faire que des
lois il fallait aussi s'assurer que
techniquement c'est possible et nous
avons plusieurs industriels français qui
ont lancé des expérimentations
d'applications simples qui viendront
chercher et stocker sur votre smartphone
une preuve anonyme de majorité preuve
anonyme de majorité qui pourra être
sollicité qui veut consulter un site
porno sera obligé de porter la preuve
qu'il est majeur oui mais de manière
anonyme pour garder la protection des
données personnelles
ce sera un passage obligatoire pour un
adulte qui va le consulter un site porn
c'est inévitable si et si nous avons 2
millions d'enfants qui sont exposés
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas parce que ces
deux millions d'enfants veulent à tout
prix être exposés à du porno c'est bien
souvent parce que au détour d'une
recherche mais innocente sur internet il
se trouve à exposer à ces vidéos qui
sont
déversés par millions de manière
gratuite et sans filtre par ces sites
pornos irresponsables qui posent un gros
problème de santé publique à notre pays
faut-il renforcer la surveillance des
réseaux sociaux la surveillance des
réseaux sociaux nous l'avons renforcé si
l'on peut dire avec ses règles
européennes que la France apportait en
2022 quand la France présidait l'Union
européenne oui c'est important de le
rappeler c'est un règlement qui
s'appelle le Règlement sur les services
numériques auparavant
il était impossible au quasi impossible
d'aller chercher la responsabilité de
réseaux sociaux lorsque des drames s'y
produisent désormais et c'est une
révolution le monde entier nous regarde
il va regarder la manière dont on met en
oeuvre cette réglementation les
plateformes ont une responsabilité elles
devront retirer les contenus qui leur
sont signés elles devront faire auditer
leurs algorithmes elles devront partager
leur donner avec les chercheurs et c'est
très important elles devront analyser et
corriger le risque qu'elles font peser
sur la santé des utilisateurs sur le
discours civique sur la sécurité
publique donc lorsque des réseaux
sociaux seront dévoyés pour et bien
capter l'attention des plus petits pour
propager de la désinformation pour
faciliter le des rassemblements et
Métiers elles auront une
responsabilités par exemple menaçant des
policiers bien sûr ça mais pas seulement
je dirais des contenus menaçants des
policiers on est bien d'accord
absolument et les contenus à plein je
sais pas moi des émeutes ou bien sûr
mais des manifestations interdites tout
ça en réalité ça sera désormais le cas
dans toute l'Union européenne en droit
français c'est le droit français avait
un peu anticipé mais mais ça va plus
loin que ça c'est à dire que non
seulement le devant de la liberté
individuelles elles devront retirer les
les les contenus ou les messages
menaçant les policiers mais de manière
plus profonde elle devrait modifier les
paramètres de leurs algorithmes les
algorithmes c'est ce qui fait que vous
voyez tel ou tel contenu sur sur un
réseau social comme Instagram ou sur
TikTok eldorant modifier les paramètres
si il est avéré que ça fait peser un
risque sur la santé des utilisateurs sur
la désinformation ou sur la sécurité
publique des policiers et ensuite la
liberté vous avez raison la limite c'est
la liberté d'expliquer la liberté
retirer obliger le retrait des contenus
menaçants des policiers ces non ou pas à
vos yeux non
bien sûr il faut il faut tout ce qui est
illégal en ligne hors ligne doit l'être
en ligne et il est illégal de menacer un
policier mais il faut être toujours
vigilant quand on encadre les réseaux
sociaux de pas porter une atteinte trop
forte à la liberté d'expression parce
qu'il faut se rappeler que les réseaux
sociaux c'est aussi dans d'autres pays
qui n'ont pas la protection de nos
institutions démocratiques un moyen pour
celles et ceux dont on veut dont on veut
brimer la liberté d'expression et bien
de s'exprimer
est-ce qu'il faut renforcer
[Musique]
la cybersécurité oui évidemment à
l'approche des Jeux Olympiques
évidemment vous attendez à quoi à des
millions qu'est-ce que je dis des
dizaines de millions et même des
milliards de tentatives de mail et SMS
frauduleux par exemple absolument et
nous avons tous reçu un faux SMS du
compte personnel de formation nous
disons qu'il faut qu'on se dépêche
d'aller payer une amende ou qu'on se
rende sur notre compte pas mal de
formation président de la République à
cet engagé pendant sa campagne a créé un
filtre anti-arnaque c'est-à-dire et bien
un dispositif qui fait que lorsque nous
cliquons sur ces liens qui nous sont
proposés par ces faux SMS plutôt que de
nous envoyer vers ce site frauduleux
nous enverra vers une page sécurisée et
ça c'est très important parce
qu'effectivement ces arnaques ou ses
tentatives d'arnaques elles vont se
multiplier à l'approche des JO et qui
sont les principales victimes et bien
c'est évidemment les Français les plus
modestes ou les plus vulnérables et les
plus âgés et il nous faut donc les
protéger c'est une des mesures très
importantes du projet de loi qui je le
souhaite sera adopté largement à
l'Assemblée nationale et là aussi c'est
un sujet de loi c'est un sujet juridique
mais c'est un sujet technique et donc
depuis des mois nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des administrations qui vont
être concernées pour que tout cela soit
prêt et croyez moi c'est un vaste
chantier est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y
a des menaces sur les élections
européennes parce qu'il y a des
cyber-attaques on le sait à des fins
politique politicienne il y a
l'intelligence artificielle qui permet
aujourd'hui de fabriquer de faux
articles de presse qui
permettent de reprendre le graphisme de
grands journaux enfin on l'a vu avec le
New York Times on le voit avec les
journaux français aussi absolument il y
a des risques un peu des attaques ces
derniers temps de nouvelles attaques ces
derniers temps écoutez le dernier le
dernier épisode qu'on a qu'on a connu
c'est celui des présidentielles et des
législatives 2022 ce sont à l'époque si
tentatives d'ingérence étrangère qui ont
été détectés par le service qui a été
créé par le Président de la République
qui s'appelle vigime et qui veille sur
les réseaux sociaux à contrer ce type de
tentative l'année prochaine pour les
élections européennes nous nous
attendons évidemment à ce type de
tentative vous avez raison de signaler
que l'arrivée de l'intelligence
artificielle bien sûr générative est un
sujet de vigilance particulière parce
qu'on va pouvoir éventuellement
contacter fabriquer etc mais
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
c'est un couteau à double lame il peut
faire du mal mais il peut aussi faire du
bien et ce que je souhaite et ça sera
c'est l'un des sujets que j'ai souhaité
confier
aux états généraux de l'information qui
vont commencer dans dans quelques
semaines que le Président de la
République a souhaité lancer ce sujet là
comment utiliser ces nouveaux outils qui
arrivent du faux ouais non pas pour
diffuser de les fausses informations
mais plutôt pour faire échec aux
tentatives
Jean-Noël barreau question politique
vous êtes vice-président du MoDem est-ce
que vous souhaitez qu'il y ait un
candidat MoDem à la présidentielle en
2027 je souhaite évidemment que notre
sensibilité cette sensibilité démocrate
qui est celle du MoDem que François
Bayrou porte qu'il a porté aux élections
présidentielles à plusieurs reprises
elle soit représentée je crois
d'ailleurs que vous écartez la
possibilité
d'un François Bayrou candidat à la
présidentielle vous pouvez comme moi
Jacques Bourdin que François Bayrou
entretient une relation particulière
avec les Français mais 2027 est encore
loin oui c'est encore loin mais vous
n'écartez pas cette candidature je vous
le dis il a depuis des années tissées et
cultivé une relation toute particulière
quoi qu'il arrive il jouera un rôle
important
dans cette élections
carrément pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
enfin nous verrons vous avez raison 2027
c'est pas c'est encore long c'est pas
tout de suite c'est encore loin bien et
bien j'en ai ah oui tiens une dernière
question est-ce que vous seriez allé en
avion à Rennes
38 minutes
en TGV c'est ce qu'on fait Elisabeth
borne et Gérald
darmaninité pour la pour la première
ministre et pour le musée éducation
nationale pour qui pour lesquels hier
était une journée quand même très très
importante et cruciale c'est 12 millions
de de d'élèves qui ont regagné les
classes ça aurait été de se déplacer en
région parisienne moi je salue le choix
qui est d'accord d'aller me répondez pas
d'aller en région à Rennes je ne suis
pas ministre de l'éducation nationale en
tout cas
ma connaissance on a compris je sais que
vous n'êtes pas ministre d'éducation
jamais est-ce que vous seriez en aller
en avion Rennes moi je vous pose la
question répondez-moi franchement non
vous auriez pris le train non je crois
qu'il était important de montrer que la
rentrée ça n'est pas qu'à Paris que le
gouvernement
d'accords
57 vous êtes sur